for a party that spent years tied up
with the russia collusion hoax two
failed impeachments a smear campaign of
brett kavanaugh and the revamping of
election laws the democrats sure do love
to tout that the end of democracy is
nigh you know what they'll ask me
is america going to be all right
what about democracy in america if
especially he had a congress
that would do his bidding
you will not recognize our country i
think that could be the end of our
democracy the demise of democracy it's
happening before our eyes they reward
those uh the republicans essentially not
all but most republicans with power
which puts us one step closer to
basically ending this democracy
what does that mean
the end of our democracy
well it really means they're losing
joe biden's agenda is failing and their
poll numbers are sinking like the
lusitania
it's not democracy that isn't working
it's just that right now it's not
working for them so like i said the
other night it's time to change the
rules of the game before the clock runs
out on their majority if you lose change
the game federalize elections widespread
mail-in balloting pack the courts
it's happening every day right under our
noses don't believe me just take a look
at hillary's hatchet attorney mark elias
who's already openly plotting to change
the next election
republicans are worse than ever and
their attack on democracy continues for
22 and 24 our best hope remains new
federal legislation and aggressive
litigation
change the game
[ __ ] democracy all in the name of
saving democracy victor davis hansen has
written extensively on this and he joins
us now vdh great to see you tonight
what is the true attack on democracy
well it's not what they're what they're
saying
will they have a talking point if you
notice it's an echo chamber atlantic
magazine new york times washington post
adam schiff hillary clinton so they've
got a talking point and says
let's say that democracy is going to end
in 2024 maybe 2022 some of them have a
little variation so what's changed from
remember november of 2020 when they told
us democracy worked really well it was
resilient it was tough it was stood the
trump challenge the system was sound so
what's changed in the the 11 months and
that is that joe biden has the lowest uh
poll numbers of any first year
president in modern memory and that
every single issue is not only that he's
enacted his policy has not only hurt the
country
but it has no support
so they're mad as you say they're not
mad that democracy isn't working they're
worried that it's going to work too well
and they're going to lose power and it's
really ironic and they're always guilty
of projection so here are people who
have been working 24 7. let's get rid of
the 233 year old electoral college
because we don't have any more
confidence in the blue wall every every
four years let's get rid of uh 233 years
old prerogative of the states that set
their own ballot laws in national
election let's get rid of a 180-year
custom of the filibuster let's get rid
of 150 years of nine person supreme
court it could go on 60 years of 50
states just because they can't get
another four senators without that so
they are the radicals that want to
change the constitutional
republic into a radical jacobin i don't
know what you would call it a mobocracy
and they're angry because they're
they're terrified they're going to lose
power and when they lose power the
system
doesn't work and when it they get back
power the system runs beautifully and as
simple as that
well i don't know that it is as simple
as that you made something very
complicated simple for us
it is absolutely undeniable that one
party is looking to change the
foundation of the american system and
you so eloquently laid out the many ways
they are attempting to do so from the
supreme court to the number of states
in this country and yet they've
developed this verbal tick victor of
the republicans are going to end
democracy and it seems like the
democratic party does adopt these verbal
ticks they kind of come in and out of
fashion maybe in 12 18 month cycles you
know racial justice in democracy where
do these come from and by the way as
long as we're at it tell us what the
next one will be if you have any insight
they come from political handlers
because these are not imaginative people
they're not independent thinking people
they get an
some kind of politico to give a you know
email these are the talking points for
the next three weeks just keep drilling
into the american people they have very
little confidence in the intelligence of
the united american people who are a lot
smarter than they are and you know they
do two things they try to change the
system and they try to change the
demography by opening the border and
welcoming and they're both blowing up in
their face they got an unpopular present
they got an unpopular agenda they got
backlash at these efforts to change the
system and now we see in the wall street
journal poll that a lot of hispanics
are tired of being talked down to by
these elite people and i think they're
going to lose a lot of the people uh in
the hispanic community and as soon as
they do you watch what'll happen they'll
say we got to close the borders we've
got to make sure we you know that we
don't have any illegal immigration even
though they thought this was going to be
a big bonanza so they have no principled
agenda no trajectory that's based on
facts and empiricism they just are sort
of like a you know a billiard ball they
just bounce all over depending where
they feel the route to power and control
is
well there's about it's a little over a
year left with the majority of their
power with a majority in power and it
will see which rule we'll see which rule
they're successful in changing be it
supreme court justices be it
federalizing the election but this will
be the priority this will be the new
year's resolution this will be 2022.
victor davis hanson so insightful thank
you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else